but you want to immune confidence and
basically say to me with your eyes
i'm ready to rumble you want a rock
bring it on i can tell right there
from the aura the vibe
you haven't even said a word yet and i
know right there
if you're a winner or a loser and i'm
never wrong
you know people smell bs a mile away so
i don't like promote things i don't use
because the mr wonderful name is
valuable and i don't put my stamp of
approval on just any product
teach handling makes starting and
maintaining a skin care routine
uncomplicated by giving you all the
products to obtain amazing skin
i use it i recommend starting with their
level one skin care
kit the system like this it comes with a
daily face wash
two times a week exfoliating scrub a pm
moisturizer and an am moisturizer with
spf
20 all for just 25 dollars
they even include an instruction card in
every box which tells you
how to use each product how much to use
and what to order again
it's completely foolproof if you click
the first link in the description
you'll not only get the best price but
you'll also get a free gift with your
first box
click that link and get started for just
25
the one i care about the most i use
every day is the am the spf 20 i put it
on the dome of desire
i don't want to burn the dome i want to
keep it just looking perfect all the
time
the wash is great too they're really
easy to use instructions are there
but you got to put some you know
protection that's why the spf 20 in the
morning is absolutely fantastic i know
yeah getting that
makeup out that's what the scrub's for
check this out
so what we're going to talk about today
is really financial habits habits
everybody's got to do
before they're 30. now these are pretty
simple
but i get asked this stuff all the time
all the time
number one this is the top of the hit
parade
you gotta stop buying crap that you
don't need
and there's a reason for this everybody
is programmed
society programs you advertise this
program you everybody's programming you
to spend money that's how the whole
society works that that's what capital
is all about
i mean you know the whole idea of
consumer goods and services that you
need
more of this stuff that you go into
credit to buy this stuff
that's all bad bottom line one of the
biggest spending items is clothing
you buy so much crap you don't need and
it just sits in the closet
for years until you give it to somebody
for free you wasted that dope and when i
say that it's because
if you take that money and this is like
an age-old theme
you take that money and you basically
don't
save it saving makes you nothing because
you get paid nothing in a bank
you invest it you're taking this money
that you
didn't waste by buying another pair of
jeans another pair of sneakers
five dollar coffee no i've said that
before that's a total waste of dough
you start saving like five bucks a day
ten bucks a day
fifty bucks a week you'd be amazed over
your career how much that's worth
as it compounds at six seven eight
percent a year so that's number one you
absolutely have to be very careful about
that
makes no sense now before i get this
going
what you want to do is pay off your
credit card debt
i can't tell you how you get screwed
on credit card interest 17 18
19 20 21
don't get sucked into that don't let
that happen to you
i can't make 18 in the market and be
guaranteed it like a credit card gets it
and charging you on your interest
that's why i own all the credit
companies stocks because they're doing
it for me but don't let me make money
off you that's dumb
basically pay off your credit card debt
before you do anything else because it's
the best investment you could have
it's such high interest rate all right
now another discipline and this is an
earned attribute in other words you have
to learn how to do this and stick true
to it
you take 10 percent of your paycheck
every two weeks 10 percent whatever it
is after tax
whatever you got and you stick it into
your robo app
the one that's investing automatically
for you doesn't have to complicate it
download it from any one of these robo
apps
right on your phone set it up to your
bank account where basically your
paycheck's often deposited
and take 10 force yourself to do that
that's after you've paid off the credit
card debt right
because that's the one you're guaranteed
to make 21
because you're paying off something
that's charging you 21 you want to do
that
and this whole idea of this 10 is not
into the savings account yes you can
have some cash around you need to have
some cash
generally 90 days worth of your living
expenses is a nice little safety net in
case of catastrophe
but you start investing
you get indexed into the market that's
what it's called
and you get a basket of stocks and it
works for you really
really important these are not
complicated things to do
it's the discipline of doing them it's
so hard saving 10 every week once you
get in the groove and you start to watch
how your money grows
right on your phone that's interesting
really interesting
paying off your credit card debt painful
but very important because you know
you're getting screwed
crap i've said don't buy crap 15 times
now because i want to drill it in your
head
don't buy crap don't buy crap
don't buy crap don't buy crap you don't
need crap have that little self on your
shoulder
i'll go on your shoulder pretend it's me
saying don't buy that crap don't buy
that crap
don't buy that crap you don't need to
buy that crap and that's how you're
going to save a ton of money
let's talk a little bit about investing
in yourself
you know what what does that mean this
might be something that you know you're
reluctant to do
but like they say you got to spend money
to make money it's true well you have to
invest in yourself
there's a lot of benefits to investing
in yourself
as well as many potential ways to invest
in yourself it's
true do you have a skill you need to
learn
maybe improve or master the difference
investing in the right tools or classes
can make this huge
in other words you go to school for
yourself you find something you like to
do
maybe it's going to be a side hustle
maybe it's something you do at night but
you'll learn about it right now if you
could do
digital marketing that's pretty hot in
the economy right now because digital
2.0 is sweeping the nation
all these companies big and small are
trying to figure out how
to sell direct to consumers well those
skill sets are understand the algorithms
in social media
photography video editing storytelling
web design digital imagery animation
all these things used to be oh that was
a purvey of the starving artist
starving artist remember that they're
not starving anymore because it turns
out that all of these skills are
really important in the new 2.0 america
that came out of the pandemic
so these skills can be learned sometimes
just trained or
online lessons or even go to college at
night these things
college is going to open up this fall
you may want to try this stuff
and learn these skills in addition to
the job you have it's like a side hustle
nothing wrong with it can be very very
useful that's the whole idea
you know applying a new skill every few
months you know every few years
you know you don't really have years to
waste that's why you want to invest
now and learn something now let me tell
you another story i think you're going
to find interesting
you know me from shark tank right listen
to what i'm saying here
i've been doing it for 13 years when
those people come in the shark tank
they're sitting right in front of me i
should say standing they're standing
right in front of me
and what you don't know is that at the
beginning of their pitch
we've got a jib like a camera that flies
in from the sky on this
big jib and there's also a guy on what's
called a steadicam
which is a camera attached to his body
that he can walk around
and it's got a stabilizing device in it
and that's that famous shot you see of
the entrepreneur standing there and then
their product behind them
that jib shot and that steadicam shot or
the setup to the whole presentation they
haven't said a word yet and the
floor director says them don't say
anything just stand there while we get
these shots
sometimes it takes a minute sometimes it
takes two minutes
well let me tell you what i do
i'm right in front of them sitting in
that chair and i'm like this
i look them right in the eye i don't
blink
i don't stare away i just look at them
just like this don't look away
you can see me do it if you look closely
i don't stop looking
why am i doing this i want to see what
happens
and i'll tell you something i've learned
i've done it thousands of times
thousands of times i can tell right then
from the aura the vibe
you haven't even said a word yet and i
know right there
if you're a winner or a loser
and i'm never wrong ever
you haven't even said a word yet in your
pitch and i know whether you're going to
walk out of there with a million dollars
or something or nothing
how do i do that it's in the
eyes how do you project confidence
it's how you look and how you feel
and how you project it right out of your
eyes you only get one
chance in your life to make a first
impression and you have to elude
confidence even though you're nervous
sure you're in the shark tank for the
first time you're probably sweating
bullets
but you want to elude confidence you
want to look
right back in the eye stare right back
and basically say to me with your eyes
i'm ready to rumble you want a rock
bring it on that's confidence that's
what matters
you have to do that every day of your
life you're going to have situations for
the rest of your life when you walk in a
room and nobody knows who you are how do
you look how do you feel
how do you project that confidence
that's what it takes if you like that
video wait did you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe